et on reste en france et c'est une
nouvelle directive du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a adressé le
29 septembre un courrier aux préfets
pour leur demander de reconduire
systématiquement les étrangers ayant
commis des infractions graves ou
représentant une menace grave pour
l'ordre public comme ils l'indiquent sur
twitter un décompte du nombre de
reconduites doit lui être adressées je
cite personnellement et chaque trimestre
alors faut-il systématiquement
reconduire à la frontière les étrangers
menaçant l'ordre public que faire
lorsqu'ils sont mineurs c'est l'objet de
notre face à face et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec pierre henry président
de l'association france fraternité
bonsoir joue souvent à vos côtés julien
haut doubs le membre du bureau national
du rassemblement national conseiller
municipal de sens bonsoir bonsoir
alors la question de la reconduite
messieurs systématique des étrangers
menaçant l'ordre public a été donc mis
sur la table par gérald darmanin après
l'attaqué dans les anciens locaux de
charlie hebdo cette semaine attaque
perpétrée par un jeune homme pakistanais
est présenté au début comme un mineur un
au début de l' enquête
thierry henry je me tourne vers vous la
proposition de gérald darmanin quand il
s'agit d'une personne majeure
est ce qu'elle vous semblent de bon sens
c'est ce qu'elle vous choque
et concernant les mineurs est ce qu'il
faut faire une distinction écouter la
proposition de gérald armen est tout à
fait logique et tout est fait normal et
e
elle a déjà eu lieu auparavant les
autres beneath de l'intérieur on dit
tous la même chose bien entendu qu'il
faut reconduire les personnes qui sont
et qui représente un véritable danger
pour l'ordre public mais simplement nous
sommes dans un système de droit et donc
c'est d'abord à la justice évidemment de
dire ce qu'est la menace public et à
partir de là si rien ne s'oppose à
l'expulsion de la personne évidemment
et dès lors qu'elle a commis des faits
d'une gravité au talent que son
expulsion doit avoir lieu et bien que
celle ci se déroule ensuite vous poser
une autre question qui est beaucoup plus
complexe et qui concerne les mineurs non
accompagnés parce que c'est ça que vous
avez en tête et simplement je rappelle
qu'il y à une convention internationale
de protection de l'enfance et que dès
lors que l'on est reconnue mineurs
eh bien on rentre dans cette protection
voilà ensuite qu'il y ait des trous dans
la raquette ça c'est un autre problème
julien houle est ce que vous partagez ce
constat qu effectivement bien la justice
et existe déjà donc on laisse passer la
justice
et s'il le faut alors on renvoie les
étrangers majeurs cette fois
malheureusement la justice n'existe pas
clairement cela fait des années que nous
avons des immigrés illégaux
quelquefois délinquants quelquefois
criminels qui ne sont même pas envoyé
dans leur pays
donc c'est vrai que le petit courrier de
monsieur darmanin c'est de la
communication c'est de l'opportunisme
mais met clairement aujourd'hui quand on
voit qui est que nous avons jeunes
confrontés à une vague d'immigration
massive que nous sommes confrontés à une
filière donc via ces faux mineurs isolés
parce qu'encore une fois la majorité
d'entre eux sont majeurs ça a été prouvé
par un rapport du sénat 60% d'entre eux
donc son sont majeurs et nous avons la
capacité dans notre droit de contrôler
leurs minorités notamment en exigeant
des tests osseux donc clairement il faut
avoir une politique d'extrême fermeté
fermeté d'une part protéger les français
parce qu'on l'a constaté notamment dans
plusieurs grandes villes à bordeaux que
c'est faux mineurs isolés et est
responsable de nombreuses violences
de nombreux cambriolages nombreuses
dégradations
on l'a vu
finalement avec ce terroriste islamiste
donc qui s'est fait passer pour pour
mineurs qui a été accueillie qui a été
hébergée qui a été nourri qui a été
choyé par le peuple français
et comme remerciement il nous a donné
des coups de hachoir je tiens à rappeler
quand même que ça a un coût et que ce
coup il est exorbitant ces cinquante
mille euros par an et par migrants c'est
à dire que ce terroriste islamiste a
bénéficié depuis son arrivée sur le
territoire national deux cent cinquante
mille euros de la poche des français
parce que c'est pas l'argent des belles
macron sait même pas l'argent de toutes
ces associations pro migrants c'est
l'argent des français c'est l'argent des
impôts donc clairement c'est d'une part
un coût exorbitant 2 milliards d'euros
pour tous ces mineurs isolés ensuite
c'est une injustice majeure parce que
quand dans notre pays on a un français
sur trois qui n'arrivent pas à se
soigner
on a un français sur cinq qui ne mange
pas à sa faim on a quatre millions de
mal logés
c'est totalement injustifiée et
injustifiable de donner autant d'argent
à des étrangers qui encore une fois ne
mérite pas la générosité hospitalité de
la france a bien henry sur le coup a le
cou l'accueil de deux de ces mineurs
étrangers
vous rejoignez le constat de julien rul
mais non d'abord monsieur oudoul une
technique qui est assez élaboré et le
mensonge chez lui est une seconde nature
le nombre de mineurs présents sur le
territoire national est prise en charge
par les départements s'élève aujourd'hui
à 16 me il y as je le disais tout à
l'heure un certain nombre de trous dans
la raquette autour de la détermination
de l'âge parce que la détermination de
l'âge se fait sur la base d'un
référentiel qui date de 1930 qui
présente des incertitudes d'environ 18
mois et cela est un véritable problème
parce que vous peut s'interroger sur la
raison pour laquelle alors que nous
sommes en 2020 nous n'avons pas un outil
fiable
deux mesures de l'achat c'est le premier
élément est donc il y a aucune raison de
faire une corrélation d'établir un lien
entre immigration et terrorisent ça
c'est de la paresse intellectuelle je
voudrais rappeler là monsieur au dol qui
lie à nombre de terroristes a un qui
sont nationaux qui ne viennent pas de
l'immigration il n'y a pas de lien à
faire entre les deux c'est quelque chose
qui peut plaire aux électeurs de
monsieur odoul qui sont particulièrement
crédules mais ce n'est pas la réelle
ensuite la prise en chasse
vous répondez l'est la prise en charge
des mineurs isolés étrangers comme la
prise en charge des mineurs nationaux un
coup ce coup il est celui de
l'éducation et il n'y a aucune espèce de
réseaux de faire une distinction entre
les deux voilà moi je suis favorable à
ce que on remette sur la table
toute la question de la protection de
l'enfance et que l'on est sûr notamment
à l'entrée véritablement de l'âge de la
personne ça me paraît normal dans un
dispositif pour mineurs il doit y avoir
des mineurs et non pas des machins
julien audois là mais ensuite mais
ensuite c'est beaucoup trop simple de
sortir un certain nombre de chiffres
et puis de balancer à la figure des
auditeurs la situation de précarité qui
prévaut dans la société française pour
mieux stigmatiser les étrangers mais
c'est un discours assez classique
julien au double je vous laisserai pas
julien ollioules je vous laisse répondre
tout de suite avant on va regarder ce
que disait françois xavier b des amis
députés les républicains au parlement
européen il s'est exprimé sur le sujet
vendredi chez nos confrères de france
info de france info pardon je vous
propose de regarder ce qu'ils disaient
vous réagissez ensuite julien odoul
aujourd'hui 60% des violences commises
dans l'espace public à paris le sont par
des mineurs étrangers non accompagnés
il y à une hypocrisie massif sur le
sujet des mineurs étrangers dans notre
pays dont tout le monde sait
parfaitement que beaucoup d'entre eux ne
sont de toute évidence pas des mineurs
et profitent en réalité de la tolérance
incroyable que nous avons à l'égard du
statut qu'ils se voient reconnaître le
gouvernement actuel est coupable d'une
faute très grave sur ce sujet là
puisqu'il ya quelques mois à travers la
loi asile et immigration
il a étendu le regroupement familial des
mineurs en permettant à ces mineurs de
faire venir toute leur famille julien
o'neal finalement vous rejoignez un ce
constat de françois-xavier bellamy un
passé plus tôt françois xavier mélanie
qui rejoint le constat de marine le pen
j'ajoute que la droite est très mal
placée pour donner des leçons en la
matière puisqu'ils n'ont jamais rien
fait pour lutter contre l' immigration
anarchique qui n'ont jamais
rien fait pour éviter donc les trafics
d'êtres humains parce que ce qui
m'interpelle mois dans le discours de
monsieur c'est finalement vous
encourager les trafiquants d'êtres
humains avec ces politiques là avec ces
incitations avec cet humanisme dévoyé
parce que l'humanité la première
humanité déjà c'est de choyer en tout
cas c'est le soigner c'est de s'occuper
des siens quand dans votre famille vous
n'arrivez pas à soigner vos enfants vous
n'arrivez pas à donner à manger à vos
enfants vous n'arrivez pas les loger il
ne faut pas s'intéresser aux voisins ou
à celui du village d'à côté c'était du
bon sens et charité bien ordonnée de
jean marie matte et en 2e marié lors de
l'épreuve sur ces mineurs en fait ces
politiques là arrache des enfants des
jeunes des adolescents quand ils sont
mineurs à leur famille dans leur pays
d'origine et la responsabilité d'un
véritable humanisme serait fait
finalement ne te les origines qui ne
sont pas des pays en guerre pour la
plupart parce que c'est la côte d'ivoire
parce que c'est des pays du maghreb
parce que c'est le sénégal parce que
c'est ghana et c'est donc ce ne sont pas
des pays en guerre
donc pourquoi les faire venir chez nous
pourquoi les paires et les faire prendre
en charge par la collectivité nationale
par les impôts des français
quand encore une fois nous à julien
autant de ponts julien aux demeures et
autant de soucis notamment julien ou non
on va entendre pierre henry notamment
sur sur cette question d'encourager les
trafics humains est ce que c'est le cas
selon vous ou comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait prendre en amont le problème de
la venue de ces de ses enfants
sur le territoire français ces enfants
étrangers oui monsieur odoul c'est pas
parce que vous avez une grande gueule
que vous êtes obligé en permanence de
franchir un mur d imbécillité des
insanités que vous délivrez en
permanence sur la caisse sur la question
du trafic
l'autre personne évidemment ne va
chercher ces jeunes gens qui fuient des
situations de guerre des devises ère
économique et qui risquent leur vie sur
la route migratoire personnes si la
fameuse notion de l'appel d'air qui est
celle qui est développé par le front
national et par monsieur odoul est une
notion stupide c'est notre démocratie
c'est notre système social qui
évidemment elle peut attirer un certain
nombre de jeunes gens qui n'ont aucun
avenir dans leur pays des personnes et
s'il ne va les chercher et je suis le
premier à le punir tous ceux et toutes
celles qui font commerce du trafic
d'êtres humains mais monsieur odoul ne
fait pas un trafic d'êtres humains mais
par contre il fait de la question de
l'immigration
un véritable business et c'est le
business de l'aisne c'est le sens des
business du refus de l'autre blessé
le business ou des permanents pardon et
et et écoutez écoutez vous écouter vous
également parce qu'il ya ces fours vous
entend pas et ça va pas être très clair
c'est qu'ils considèrent qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés dans notre pays
ils n'en veulent plus ils n'en peuvent
plus je viens au nom le compte tenu des
déficits contenus de nos comptes sociaux
julien eau douce est vrai qu'à porter
assistance à ces mineurs c'est aussi
l'adn de la france pays des droits de
l'homme fidh a man qu'est ce qui vous
pose problème au fond mais encore une
fois nous sommes un pays d'asile mais v
sauf que le problème c'est qu'elle
demande d'asile la demande
il a été dévoyé la demande d'asile c'est
quoi c'est quelqu'un qui est percé
cumulé en politiquement personnellement
dans son pays pour des raisons
religieuses pour des raisons de
philosophie fondée raison d'orientations
sexuelles c'est asia bibi au pakistan et
d'autres c'est salman rushdie c'est ça
la zil ce ne sont pas des populations
entières qui encore une fois ne viennent
pas de pays en guerre
ce sont des filières d'immigration
économique qui profite de notre
générosité qui profitent de la
générosité de l'état français et encore
une fois je le dis c'est les français
qui payent et compte tenu aujourd'hui de
la situation économique qui est un autre
9 millions de pauvres 6 millions de
chômeurs 4 millions de mal-logés un
français sur trois qui ne se soigne pas
nous avons un système hospitalier pour
la crise du coronavirus a montré qu'il
était en lambeaux
nous avons encore une fois un système
hospitalier qui manquent de lits de
réanimation et au contraire de voir un
gouvernement qui préfère ouvrir 4000
places pour les demandeurs d'asile alors
qu'il faudrait plutôt 4000 lits de
réanimation région clairement nous ne
pouvons pas de les lire et le bon sens
c'est plutôt de s'occuper des français
qui souffrent avant de s'occuper de la
terre entière
pierrot rire on vous laisse le mot de la
fin il nous reste quelques secondes pour
conclure oui bah vous savez vous savez
nous sommes en faire une période de
creux vide et il suffit de demander aux
personnes qui hélas ont fait un passage
par l'hôpital et qui en sont sortis qui
donc les a soignés dans les hôpitaux
ce sont ces personnes que sont en train
de cuisses tiges et le rassemblement
national et monsieur odoul l'immigration
c'est aussi on l'est plus lorsque celle
ci est tout à fait maîtrisé
donc aucun amalgame à feurs il y a de la
fermeté à avoir des lents que les règles
sont enfreintes qu'elles sont qu'il ya
des fraudes mais évidemment je rejette
tous les discours de haine
et d'instrumentaliser et tu as les
questions migratoires à des fins
électorales telles que le boeuf le fait
monsieur au dos merci en tout cas à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté le jeu du débat
merci à vous bien henry je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'association
france fraternité merci à vous julien
houde où le membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national
conseiller municipal de sens